you're not that guy pal trust me you're
not that guy just total Uncle energy
you're not that guy you're not that guy
that's [__] amazing how's that how's
that
dude one time my uncle
said to my cousin my cousin was like
complaining about like yeah I don't know
I don't really want to go to college
this was his high school and my uncle
had this energy and he just says don't
go
don't go then don't go he it's like
that's that Uncle energy is like already
right there
don't go
and you could tell like they talked
about it already so you could tell like
something already has been happening in
this they're in a supermarket
oh how's that how's that
yep how's that
with his hands and his pockets
[__] you where you could breathe oh yeah
[__] you where you breathe how's it
with his hands in his pockets
looking for change
[__] you where you breathe roll and lint
around couldn't be more casual telling a
guy is gonna [__] his mouth
house out
unreal guy [__]
unreal guys wearing the last remaining
Union Bay shirt
don't tell me what the [__] to do how's
that pal
don't tell me what to do how's that pal
still hands in the pocket
bro let me tell you right now you come
at me with that energy and you have your
hands in your pocket
I'm Gonna Knock you in the face because
it's gonna be so easy
how about that
somehow somehow though I can tell that
even though this guy is at this level
and we have no context somehow I can
tell that this guy's in the right I
don't know why I can tell but I can tell
that this guy's in the right
I didn't tell you what you did you said
don't talk to people who you don't know
I'll talk to whoever the [__] I want to
know never mind how's that pal never
mind another how's that
dude when a guy's angry and calls people
Terms of Endearment like pal
forget it
hey pal
what's going on pal I'll [__] weird
breathe how about that pal how's that
just rolling some lint around in my
pocket just looking for some quarters
how's that pal I'll [__] you we could
breathe hell's that
oh look found two pieces of lint
look at that oh look
gotta got a straw rapper I realized I
didn't I couldn't find a trash can so I
put it in my pocket how's that pal
I found that in my left pocket and two
quarters and a dime in my right pocket
how's that Bell
[__] your [__] you where you breathe
huh
come on I did tell him not to talk
that's right so use your [__] head if
you know how understood okay you little
pimply little [__]
the illest slam I ever heard in my life
how's that your pimply little pimple
face [__]
I've never heard a slam like that the
guy came guns blazing dude
[Music]
the checkout lady ah could you guys just
not maybe I'm what I'm doing is like the
wind blowing it's not affecting anything
but I just I have to do this because the
wind has to blow so
that sounds good to me so then leave I'm
checking out sir check out ring out if
you guys if you can take it you're not
that guy pal trust me this guy is like
has the Wally backman energy where he
[__]
I gotta go back a little bit because
that's when he starts to say you're not
that guy that is just so gangster dude
you're not that guy pal trust me you're
not that guy okay yeah you absolutely
yep he is that guy can get arrested for
this arrested for doing what just like a
pimple on the left somebody says
something and you don't like it
what does it mean am I the dumb one here
what does it mean just like a pimple on
the left man somebody says something
somebody doesn't like it legit had a
[__] aneurysm right there right there
had a stroke when she was like and that
there remember the [__] newscaster
and that there um and their um their um
or he's doing the he's the male version
of the such as and such as uh well it's
a [__] pageant that Mario Lopez tried
to keep it together with his [__]
beautiful face just by smiling so how
would you solve World Peace well such as
such as if you such as such as just as
[__] [__] is leaking from her anus
just malfunctioning
I'm sorry I'm not that guy
and you don't like it right is that what
it is you're a little just pimp can you
hold the camera while I check I'll leave
the store [__] you or you believe well
right [__] you were you bleed
where do you bleed
ow
were you breathe I'll breathe now suck
right here have a good day sir oh
he's a trumpet
I'm concerned
Christ
it's not cool to take the lord's name in
vain but okay
work for Biden and suck right here pal
two things now I showed you no shut up
I don't want to go the thing is I didn't
want another video to play and you made
it happen and I didn't want that to
happen
you're not that guy
it's always a [__] video from like
Sky News what the [__] is Sky News
um
oh dude if a guy came at me with that
energy
I can't even tell you
how much I would raise that energy
like
you're not that guy
I would say oh yeah I am
and I get real close to him too
oh yeah you're not that guy you must be
mistaking me for not that guy
I mean I get he was talking to [__]
you know these people who maybe don't
deal with people that much but bro you
talk you come up to me in a frozen food
section and tell me I'm not that guy you
better believe I'm that [__]
dude I'm a hundred percent that guy
and when the guy says let's fight I say
dude we're not fighting we're [__]
dancing hit it and then somebody plays
aini Kamoze